to the new year and it might be a good
time to check in if you haven't already
to see if you're on track to keep any
resolutions you made and the district at
Green Valley Ranch is hoping it can help
and they have a whole bunch of options
for people who are looking to keep their
New Year's resolutions and to talk about
that we have Julina Breslin from the
district appreciate you being here thank
you thanks for having me a lot of people
have resolutions that are Health based
and you guys have some good options
including juices a lot of people like to
do those yeah we definitely are your
One-Stop shop for anything you could
possibly need to keep those New Year's
resolutions alive I feel like January is
a very important month for that yeah and
we have pressed for Jews right on side
they offer four different cleanses
including one that you can customize
yourself so if you're looking to
detoxify you know reset your body
they're the perfect fit you know along
with a lot of tenants that we have at
the district yeah so if after you can do
a juice before or after you work out you
guys have some places for that as well
yeah we definitely have an array of
Fitness Studios including bar three a
pilates studio as well as Mayweather
boxing and fitness
yeah so we have everything for everyone
you know we have cyclebar as well yeah a
lot of options you know to keep those
New Year's resolutions going and I feel
like all of our fitness Studios offer
like first free complimentary classes so
it's a great way to try each one of them
why not you know and just decide what
you like best yeah and some folks may
want to take on a new look in 2023 and
you have some salons that can help with
that definitely we have if you're
looking to you know get new bangs or
change that hair color you know refresh
your look we have Aveda Salon and Spa on
site you should treat yourself to a
blowout dry bar as well as you know know
give yourself the gift of eyelashes at
the Lash Lounge they're perfect you know
you can just wake up and start your day
without any makeup so many other options
but before we go we just have a little
bit of time you have a contest going on
where people can win some some money to
spend at the district yeah we have an
amazing new year new me enter to win
it's valued at over a hundred dollars in
gift cards to Whole Foods where you can
get your produce and organic groceries
as well as Lululemon you know to get
your workout going cycle bar
Sephora we have a lot of our
Merchants at the district to help you
you know keep those New Year's
resolutions alive I like it as you said
January is an important time to do that
you can get off track at this point
julisa thank you so much for being here